towards the end of Scream 6 we see a
quick shot of the contacts list on Sam's
phone one of which is Christy in my
scream 2022 video I pointed out the
Easter eggs hidden in the contacts on
Dewey's phone and the meaning behind
Christy and the other names listed so
this is our clue to be on the lookout
for references again so let's go through
her contacts Tara is her sister the
Jenna Ortega character but Meyer is the
son of Scream 6 producer William
Sherrick the next name is Eloise she's
the daughter of William sharek the next
name after that is Nikki the fifth and
sixth screen were directed by Matt
bettinelli open and Tyler Gillette who
did a segment in the anthology horror
film VHS where one of the characters is
named Nick I'm not sure about River it's
too common of a word to search but I did
figure out that Eileen is Eileen Jones
the wife of Tyler Gillette Mindy and
Chad are the twins from the movie Sydney
is the main protagonist of the franchise
who isn't in this one Jay is the film's
editor Jay perchidni and tiefer is the
post-production assistant Tyler Ferguson
I wasn't able to find a mini and Rebecca
could refer to several people but that's
just a taste of the level of detail that
this movie's Secrets have to offer if
you want to know the scream origins of
every single prop in the movie theater
Shrine all of the costume references on
the subway train and info hidden in hard
to find places stick around to the end
of this video this video is sponsored by
Factor
[Music]
welcome to things you missed just one
year after the franchise was revived
with stream 2022 the next sequel would
already be released mirroring the quick
turnaround from the original scream in
1996 to Scream 2 in 1997. this would be
our first of many clues that scream 6
was going to be a recoil of scream 2. in
the same way that the last movie was a
recall of the original for the third
movie in a row they changed the naming
Convention of the title the fourth movie
moved the number inside the word scream
which was cool everybody likes it when I
call it screen form it's not annoying
and nobody leaves anchor comments about
that at all the fifth could have gone
with five cream but instead it just
decided to call it scream to fit the
meta of recalls at the time like
Halloween and Candyman I guess Scream 6
was trying to do the best of both worlds
by doing the Standalone title but also
having the number in the M on the poster
which means they had to switch to Roman
numerals it reminds me of the Jack
franchise the first game was Jack and
Daxter the precursor Legacy then Jack 2
switches to Roman numerals Jack 3 used
Arabic numerals but then the fourth one
was called Jack X but it wasn't the
Roman numeral X it was just the letter X
anyway I'm getting off topic let's cut
in into the things you missed
[Music]
foreign
the first thing I'm going to talk about
is how similar this movie is to scream
2. while the characters do point this
out themselves step two took place in
college so do we think that the Killer
is trying to copy the movies it goes
much deeper than you might have realized
in addition to the college setting one
of the Five Ghost Face killers in this
movie Jason is introduced in the opening
where we find out that he's a student in
a class about 20th century slashers just
like the killer in Scream 2 Mickey is
introduced in the college film class
discussing the stab movie both movies
feature a main character who's dealing
with Newfound Fame after surviving
murders the previous year when a new
string of crimes begins they're both
given special police protection each has
a new boyfriend who is very suspicious
but not guilty when we're reintroduced
to Tara she's on her way to a party she
went to the Omega Kappa beta party it's
the same fraternity that Derek belonged
to in Scream 2. we even briefly see
their coat of arms that matches the
necklace that Derek gave Sydney at the
party we learned that Tara is
considering joining sorority called
Omega betazeta
which is the same one that CeCe Cooper
was a part of in 1997. speaking of CC
Cooper she doesn't last long in the
movie getting stabbed and thrown off the
top of that sorority house she has a
counterpart in Scream 6 and Nika who
gets stabbed and tossed from the ladder
she's trying to escape on I don't know
why Dany just has a huge ladder in his
NYC apartment maybe he saw a nerve and
was inspired Tara later explains that
the core 4 moved to New York for summer
semester very similar to how Sydney and
Randy moved to Ohio mid-school year to
escape their own trauma in Woodsboro
while scram 2 was set in Ohio the
college that they filmed at was in
Atlanta Atlanta is mentioned several
times in Scream 6. It's the place where
Jason and Greg first met in middle
school and Kirby works for the FBI's
Atlanta field office could be a
coincidence or maybe an intentional
connection Kirby by the way has a scar
from where Charlie stabbed her in scree
form she gets stabbed there again at the
end of Scream 6 but lives the same way
that Dewey survived and screamed too
knife winning is the most scar tissues
the same thing seems to happen to Gail
Weathers in disagree form she got it in
the shoulder and that's where the new
ghost face gets her again in six and she
manages to survive after Sam and Tara
survived the first attack Gail weathers
comes investigating in the franchise
tradition of her getting punched in the
face by the victim continues if you look
at the reaction of the cameraman it's
the same look of surprise seen on the
face of Joel her camera guy in Scream
too
the reason Gail got punched was because
Sam was unhappy with her portrayal in
Gail's latest book
unstable and a Born Killer that's taken
out of context that's literally a quote
which mirrors Dewey's frustrations with
his portrayal in the Woodsboro murders
book he too supplies her with actual
citations
Paige 41. as I mentioned the first death
out of the main cast is Anika and she's
wearing the same green jacket that Randy
wore when he became a ghost-based victim
in the second movie there's also another
reference to Randy when they're walking
through the park trying to keep
Ghostface on the line and this
similarity is called out by Mindy this
is exactly how our Uncle Randy died
however the person in danger here is
actually Gail who is at home during her
call with the killer she tries to locate
him by hanging up and calling back this
is also a reference to scream 2.
the finale of each film takes place in a
theater where all is revealed at one
point Sam grabs a brick to defend
herself with which honors the method by
which Sydney tried to defeat Billy's
mother crushing her with a pile of
bricks Quinn reveals herself as the
final Killer Hey roomies you didn't say
that one
actually I did Billy and Roman already
tried faking their deaths so it wasn't a
huge surprise more importantly her line
is almost identical to what Mickey said
after the reveal of Billy's mother it's
nice twist huh didn't see it coming did
you Mike and stream 2 the Main ghost
faces the parent of the antagonist from
the previous movie out for revenge
against their son's killer the
accomplice or in this case the
accomplices are enrolled at the
University their education being funded
by the other ghost face in Scream 2
Sydney is saved by cotton someone she
previously believed to be guilty in six
Sam and Terra are saved by Kirby who
they thought was guilty finally at the
end it turns out that Chad is somehow
alive and he's carried out in a
Stretcher with Tara running alongside
it's just like Dewey and Gail at the end
of scream 2. but there would be even
more Scream 2 references in the movie
theater along with many more hidden
secrets
[Music]
are you on a mission to make healthier
choices this summer are you on a mission
to quote every 2000's teen movie ever
this Summer's gonna be different this
Summer's gonna change our lives if you
want to make calorie conscious eating a
breeze without compromising on taste
check out Factor their delicious
dietitian approved calorie smart meals
come with around 550 calories per
serving so you can enjoy your favorite
meals guilt-free knowing that you're
staying on track with your health goals
and here's something for those of you
looking to budget this month by cutting
back on takeout why not try Factor
instead not only is Factor more
affordable than takeout but their chef
prepared meals are ready faster than
restaurant delivery in just two minutes
that's right in less than the time it
takes to choose a movie your gourmet
meal can be ready to eat as you may know
I've also worked with hellofresh who
owns factor and I'm a fan of both
hellofresh for when I want to cut things
and factor for when I'm in a hurry which
is often as a cz's world viewer you'll
get a discount on both Brands ready to
make the smart choice this summer click
the link in the description or go to
factor75.com and use code cz50 to get 50
off your first Factor box that's
factor75 com with code cz50 for 50 off
the already affordable prize this summer
is gonna be different
[Music]
part of the phone of the scream
franchise and the whodunit genre in
general is going back to see the clues
laid out for us once we know the ending
in Tara's dialogue with Quinn at the
apartment Quinn describes how her dad
held on too tight with
overprotectiveness after they lost her
brother combine that with Detective
Bailey's line after Quinn's death but my
kids are gone
my whole family
and that's two oddly specific references
to this mysterious dead sibling the
movie honestly could have used a few red
herrings to throw us off because it was
obvious that this brother was
significant add in the fact that the
first ghost face call comes from Richie
kirsch's phone and it starts to become
clear this is the same tactic that
Richie and Amber used when A call came
in from Amber's phone everyone assumed
that the killer cloned Amber's phone
number when in reality all they had to
do was use Amber's actual phone
detective bayley probably got Richie's
phone back after his death and just used
that one area where the movie did
successfully employ a red herring was in
wardrobe fans know at this point that at
least one Ghostface Killer always has a
light blue shirt or flannel in this case
it was Ethan and while I never really
suspected Terra or Sam were forced to
notice Dany wearing light blue when we
literally see him put it on someone
wearing a ghost face mask attacks Sam
and Terra outside their apartment the
same apartment where they were literally
just with Quinn and Ethan later on after
Quinn's death is staged her father comes
out of the building with a little bit of
a limp maybe from an injury sustained
when he's knocked to the floor by
Samantha and he's staring right at
Samantha as he says this with my family
you die and when Gail gets the dreaded
phone call later on it's from a 707 area
code which represents Northern
California where Woodsboro is located
that's another clue that the Killer is
from that area which rishi's family most
likely would be there's also an ominous
clue that isn't related to the identity
of the protagonist Sam's psychiatrist
can be seen watching Invasion of the
Body Snatchers which literally tells him
before he becomes the next Ghost Face
Victor as always it's one of many horror
movie references in a scream film every
Scream movie makes a reference to Psycho
with the last film even containing a
Psycho movie poster that continues here
with this poster in Jason's apartment he
also has a vertigo poster another
Thriller directed by Alfred Hitchcock in
addition to the first psycho psycho 2 is
also referenced this time psycho 2 is
underrated psycho 2 also features a
character getting stabbed through the
mouth which is exactly what Tara does to
Ethan at the end but going back to Jason
given that he's a film student and a
horror fan there are a lot of references
connected to him the reason he killed
his professor in the opening sequence
was because she gave him a c minus on
his giallo paper giallo is an Italian
murder mystery genre a perfect
counterpart to scream Jason's t-shirt
says foreign
which translates to Four Flies on the
gray velvet it's a giallo film directed
by Dario Argento about a rock musician
who becomes entangled in a gruesome
murder case interestingly Jason also has
an Ice Nine Kills magnet on his fridge
Ice Nine Kills is a metal band known for
theming their songs around horror movies
their 2018 album this Silver Screen has
a series of accompanying music videos
with a narrative throughline about a
series of deaths connected to the band's
frontman Spencer charnis so kind of
similar to Four Flies on the gray velvet
Ice Nine Kills also did a deluxe version
of the silver scream which appropriately
contains a song about scream and no it
was not lost on me that Jason gets home
and turns on a Friday the 13th movie his
full name is Jason Carvey and Jason
Voorhees the antagonist of the Friday
the 13th franchise likes to carve up his
victim this isn't just any Friday the
13th movie though it's Friday the 13th
Part 8 Jason Takes Manhattan the one
where he goes to New York much like how
Scream 6 is set in New York Jason is not
the only new character who seems to be a
horror fan Sam's psychiatrist has some
merch in his office on the desk you can
spot a lineup of horror dolls including
Gomez Pugsley and fester Adams as well
as Leatherface above the fireplace
there's also a Leatherface doll and a
ghost face doll the defunct movie
theater Marquee is advertising to events
on the left it says Jennifer Jolie
retrospective Jennifer Jolie was the
name of the actress who played Gail
Weathers in stab 3. on the right it says
Rocky Horror Picture Show which connects
to this guy dressed up as Frank and
furter from Rocky Horror on the subway
which brings me to the next section the
costumes it's always been a pet peeve of
mine in movies that take place around
Halloween when everyone is dressed in
generic costumes like vampire Pirates
nurse Etc because in real life most
people are dressed up as something
specific usually some kind of Pop
Culture thing I was glad to see scream
finally do this right and some of the
costumes have a deeper meaning like at
the Omega Kappa beta party where we see
a girl dressed as Wednesday Adams from
The Addams Family since the release of
scream 2022 the star and Jenna Ortega
portrayed this character in a popular
adaptation and known as Wednesday is the
recycling Wednesday flyer on her fridge
related to this as well probably not
other party guests include someone in a
striped ghost face mask hanging with a
Dwight Schrute from the office there's
also a girl in the crowd wearing a
number 10 Jersey a reference to the top
that Tatum wears in the first scream
which is a reference to What Glenn Lance
wore in a Nightmare on Elm Street then
we've got Harry Potter Alan from The
Hangover and Mindy Meeks who is dressed
as storm a delivery a woman known for
her part in a lesbian movement in the
1960s that's kind of her whole entire
gimmick in this movie she's constantly
advertising her homosexuality there are
even more costumes in the subway scene
first there's Grace from the 2019 movie
Ready or Not which is directed by Matt
buttonelli open and Tyler Gillette just
like this moose there's a David Bowie in
the crowd and a Michael Myers from the
Halloween franchise which is significant
because of how the scream franchise is a
satire primarily of the Halloween
franchise in fact when they arrive at
the train station you can hear people
chanting evil dies tonight less scary
serial killer movie which is the Mantra
from Halloween kills the sequel to the
recall just like how Scream 6 is a
sequel to a recall the Statue of Liberty
makes an appearance makes sense it's New
York this is mojo jojo the main villain
from the Powerpuff Girls nice to see
scream staying in touch with its 90s
Roots it's not really a costume but this
guy has a fangoria shirt it's fangoria
being the famous horror magazine on the
train there's someone dressed as the
babadook which Tara cited as her
favorite movie in the fifth screen
what's your favorite scary movie uh the
babadook other than Ghostface the train
contains a variety of other slasher
icons like Pinhead from the Hellraiser
movies Jason from Friday the 13th and
Freddy Krueger from A Nightmare on Elm
Street of course this wasn't Freddie's
first rodeo in a Scream movie there's
also someone dressed as Chucky from
Child's Play which was referenced in
Scream 2022 as an example of a horror
movie that was remade that scene also
talks about elevated horror what's wrong
with elevated horror I mean Jordan peel
[__] rules so some of the costumes in
the subway are from the elevated horror
era like Pluto from Jordan peels us as
well as several of the other tethered
characters from that movie there's also
a chick dressed as Danny arder aka the
May Queen from mid-summer right after
that there's a quick flash Cameo from a
Tyler Gillette the co-director before we
move on to some Stephen King references
including the Grady twins from The
Shining and Georgie denbro from Ed other
horror references include Melanie
Daniels from the birds complete with
bird Horace Pinker from West Raven
shocker kayako Seiki from The Grudge and
Billy the Puppet from Saw which was
mentioned in scree form did you pick a
movie yeah we're gonna go scary I saw
four it seems there are also other pop
culture references on the train like
Tyler Durden from Fight Club and I
didn't know what this was so I tried
Googling hand around the neck costume
and apparently this was just an Oscar's
dress from Julia Fox an actress from the
movie uncut gems there's one glaring
hole in the train scene they're trying
to safely travel from the upper west
side to the movie theater everyone is in
costume around them so why don't they
just get costumes to evade Ghostface
there are many hidden details in the
costumes and there may even be some that
I didn't recognize so let me know what
you saw in the comments but there are
even more secrets in the form of hidden
West Craven homages scream Easter eggs
and other things you might have missed
foreign
[Music]
you know I am very concerned with movie
timeline accuracy I have a series called
Horror history which is half character
analysis and half timeline construction
so I can be the first to say that these
last two Scream movies have screwed up
the timeline at the end of the fifth
screen the reporter claims that the
original Woodsboro Massacre was 25 years
ago almost to the deck the original was
set in 1996 so that would mean that it
was set in 2021. however Sam and Mindy
both claim that the most recent stab
came out last year and we can clearly
see that was 2021 meaning that the fifth
scream is actually set in 2022 which
seems to be backed up in Scream 6. the
Woodsboro truther subreddit refers to
the most recent events in Woodsboro is
the 2022 Woodsboro Massacre and Kirby's
timeline of events says 2022 was the
year of Richie and Amber's death however
this board also claims that Roman's
death was in 2000 which is incorrect in
Scream 3 Roman died in 1999. the
production designers obviously just used
the release dates of the movies rather
than when they are set but Kirby
specifically says that Richie and Amber
died last year so we can probably just
go with the fifth scream taking place in
2022 and the sixth scream taking place
in 2023 right well when we see the film
professor's phone at the beginning of
the movie it says Saturday October 29th
which would put this in 2022. other
phone screens also corroborate this
Sam's driver's license is two days away
from expiration although you could argue
that she's not planning on renewing it
because you don't need a car in New York
and the subway map says Service
suspended through September 2022. why
would that still be up over a year later
but on the other hand the newscaster in
Scream 6 very clearly refers to Sam as
one of the survivors of the Woodsboro
killings in 2022. so I think there's
more evidence now that scream 2022 does
in fact take place in 2022 and scream 6
takes place 13 months later in 2023.
this board also confirms that the scream
TV show is a separate Canon entirely
which I'm very much fine with look if
anyone knows the people that work on
these movies can you please just send
them my channel so they can stop
screwing up their own franchise I
usually try to find a reason to make the
mistakes work by saying things like this
character was just estimating the date
but there are only so many excuses I can
make for you Roman Bridger was the only
single Ghost Face kudos to him for
ambition that's debatable it's extremely
debatable see my Scream 3 things you
missed episode for details but not until
after you've seen all the Wes Craven
references here in Scream sets as you
know Wes Craven was the legendary horror
director who brought us everything from
Last House on the Left To The Hills Have
Eyes to A Nightmare on Elm Street and of
course the first four screens in Jason's
apartment he has a poster for last
podcast on the left a clear play on Last
House on the Left that film was released
in 1972 And in the establishing shots at
the beginning of the movie we see West
72nd Street it appears that all of the
East-West streets in Upper Manhattan
corresponds to Wes Craven release dates
the characters board a train at 94th and
93rd which corresponds to New Nightmare
and body bags respectively Gail's
apartment is located between 96 and 97.
stream came out in 1996 and Scream 2
came out in 1997. one of the posts in
the Woodsboro truther subreddit comes
from a user their names two three four
Mimi Mimi 23 Mimi Craven was Wes
Craven's wife for a short time in the
80s she appeared in a Nightmare on Elm
Street and Swamp Thing Jason and Greg's
apartment building is called Elm Court a
reference to a nightmare in Elm Street
when we see Sam's driver's license her
address is 2419 Solar Drive Modesto
California however this address is not
in Modesto it's in Los Angeles and it
once belonged to Wes Craven this next
one is one of the weirdest ever at the
end of the convenience store scene we
see the exterior of the store and it's
called Abe snake Bodega when I'm making
these videos and I see a brand name that
I don't recognize I always look it up to
find out if there's some significance so
that's what I did and I found this slash
film article which contains some odd
trivia it explains that one of Craven's
friends got involved in producing adult
films in the 70s and he decided to try
making one himself in 1975 in between
last house and 1977's The Hills Have
Eyes Craven made the fireworks woman
also known as Angela the fireworks woman
using a spectacular pseudonym Abe snake
and just like Angela was packed with a
fire Works stream 6 is packed with
Easter eggs referencing the rest of the
scream franchise if you look closely at
the Woodsboro truther subreddit which by
the way the URL is
www.r Woodsboro truther pretty sure
that's not how URLs work but you'll
notice that the sub was created 114
2022. this contradicts the timeline
again but at least this one is obviously
just an Easter egg it's technically the
theatrical release date of scream 2022
seen on posters even though the premiere
was canceled another Reddit post
advertises 261 Turner Lane part two the
all-new true story this is essentially a
story about the last movie's events
because 261 Turner Lane is the address
of the house once occupied by stewmacher
and his family before being the host of
Amber Freeman and her family I met Steve
marker's house on Turner Lane it's two
six one despite leaving Woodsboro some
of the characters still seem to have
pride about their Old Town Chad hangs on
to his letterman jacket and Mindy wears
a panther patch on hers the mascot of
Woodsboro High one of the defining
characteristics of a requel is rehashing
existing scenes and scream 6 is no
exception Sam visit the police station
following their convenience store
encounter where they're told that they
can't leave town by the detective in the
fourth scream Dewey and Judy have to
tell Sydney the same thing another
Sydney parallel can be seen as they're
leaving and the media swarm around them
just like when they mob Sydney Prescott
in 1996 outside of the Woodsboro police
station and the same music plays as well
eventually Kirby shows up now a member
of the FBI and she and Mindy test each
other on horror movie knowledge best
Nightmare on Elm Street the original
this is a reference to the original
screen where Casey Becker has similar
taste yeah Freddy Krueger Freddy that's
right I like that movie it was scary wow
well the first one was but the rest
sucked or maybe just common sense then
there's Gail during the part where she's
talking with Sam about the importance of
family we hear Dewey's theme in the
background suggesting that Gail never
stopped caring about him this is also
evident because she has the same photo
of her and Dewey that we first saw in
Dewey's trailer in the fifth one she
almost ended up joining him after an
ambush by Quinn at one point she fires
two shots through the door and says
how's that for Nostalgia referring to
when she played Hero by shooting Billy
Loomis way back in the original but it
wasn't just the dialogue that was
nostalgic because the movie theater
Shrine is packed with background detail
spanning the entire franchise
foreign
[Music]
for the final showdown Sam splits off
from her new love interest Danny for
safety reasons we don't know you
not really she says this in almost the
exact same way as her old love interest
Ritchie spoke about the stab franchise
no one has made a great movie since the
first one not really from this point on
there's a lot of familiar line delivery
I've always wanted to stick something in
you Tara can I always say that
thankfully I said the Shrine is a gold
mine for things you missed akin to
Eleanor Studio from jigsaw I'll start
with the first frame and work my way
forward this is the outfit Tatum Riley
wore on her final night this is
stu-macher's robe from the night of his
party and here's Billy loomis's shirt
from that same evening the black jacket
and backwards hat belonged to Kenny
Gail's cameraman for top story with Gale
weathers it's more obvious when you see
the back of his top story jackets this
mannequin represents Stephen orth
Casey's boyfriend and the franchise's
first on-screen kill here we have the
ghost face mask that principal Hembree
confiscated from the pranksters at the
school and cut up and these are the
scissors he used to do it two of your
fellow students just savagely murdered
and this is the way that they show your
compassion and sensitivity huh let me
tell you something you're both expelled
yeah you know I wonder if they just
showed up at school the next day it's
not like Henry had time to tell anyone
that he expelled them on top of the Mask
is the rope that Henry swung from next
to a sketch of where he was found on the
football field and his obituaries this
is an employee shirt from Bradley Video
Store the store that Randy worked at in
the first movie I'm not positive why
this is here because as far as we know
nobody died at the video store but I
guess it's possible that it was still a
scene in the movie adaptation of stab
rounding out the first movie we have the
Woodsboro High School flag Scream 2
opens with the stab movie premiere and
there's a lot of memorabilia from that
we see the costumes masks and plastic
knives that were handed out to patrons
in attendance at the premiere as well as
a few movie tickets in the corner is the
giant Ghostface head that decorated the
production office in Scream 3. this
sketch depicts Sydney at various points
in Scream 2 on stage in the government
car and at the library it's above a
Windsor College sweater the setting of
scream 2. I believe the camera that Chad
picks up and throws that Ghostface is
Joel's camera during his gig with up to
date this big old set piece along the
side of the theater is the thing that
Derek was tied to at the end of Scream 2
and at some point we can even see the
Agamemnon mask that he was wearing when
he was lowered onto the stage there's
also another mask from that play right
here there's also a glimpse of the white
Blazer that Debbie saltz Nancy Loomis
was wearing during the finale and I
believe this is the gun that she used
during that scene Scream 3 is all about
the production of the third stab movie
being terrorized by a new threat above
the stab 3 script is the Slate used
during filming however as an Easter egg
the cinematographer is listed as Brett
jukowitz the cinematographer of scream
2022 and scream sex I spotted a sketch
of Sarah Darling the first Scream 3
victim and Jennifer Jolie the actress
who played yeah also visible here is the
Killer's voice changer in gun Scream 3
had a special voice changer that allowed
the user to imitate anyone's voice kinda
funny that we've only just recently
unlocked that technology today and it's
being used to make politicians bicker
over video games in this case there's a
melted phone a frying pan and a lighter
the frying pan is the one one that the
killer used to knock out the security
guard Stephen Stone there's another
frying pan attack in this movie when
Gail uses it against Quinn I wonder if
that one will make the next Museum the
phone is Jennifer Jolie's phone damaged
when her house exploded and the lighter
must have been Tom Prince's lighter
which was responsible for causing that
explosion overhead is the banner that
says happy birthday Roman which was
displayed over the entryway of John
Milton's manner when Sydney arrived it
was not a happy birthday for Roman
screiform by the time this one rolled
around several more stab films had been
made these posters for stabs 3 4 and 5
are all in spree form but this is the
first time we've ever seen the stab 4
poster or should I say the steforb
poster unobstructed there were also
sketches of the two killers Charlie and
Jill as well as the shirt that Charlie
was wearing when he died and the flannel
that Jill had on before being taken to
the hospital and changed into a hospital
gown there's a moment where we see Kirby
looking at it with tears in her eyes
remembering the way that her best friend
betrayed her and tried to have her kill
and we also see the knife that Charlie
stabbed her with and the residue on the
patio where Kirby was tied up in the the
back here you'll see the outfit worn by
Jill's ex-boyfriend Trevor when he died
it could also potentially be Neil
Prescott's outfit from Scream 1 which
looks the same but since Neil never died
I'm guessing he got to keep his clothes
I see no reason they would have ended up
in police custody this one was the
hardest to play my first thought was
that it was supposed to be Casey Becker
and because nobody else died in a white
long sleeve but it doesn't match and she
wasn't wearing shorts my guess is that
it's actually supposed to be Jill's
neighbor Olivia Morris who was taken
down while wearing a gray long-sleeve
and flannel shorts it's not a perfect
match but it's my best guess there's
also a Woodsboro police uniform meaning
that this belonged to Deputy Haas or
Deputy Perkins the two cops who fell in
the line of duty while parked outside of
Jill's house and we have a stabathon
t-shirt stabathon was the movie marathon
event hosted by the Woodsboro High film
club where Gail weathers was nearly
butchered in addition to those there's
also a case full of Gail's books most of
which we've seen before in Scream 3 and
4 with one notable addition
thank you
[Music]
the Gale weathers book that we haven't
seen before is stabbed in the back the
real Sunrise story this actually comes
from one of the promotional websites for
scream 3. Sunrise sucks this was an
anonymous expose site that published
dirt about the production company
responsible for the stab franchise
Sunrise Studios I talked about it
extensively in my Horror history episode
on the history of the stab IP by the way
in Gale's apartment there's one new book
called The Woodsboro horror continues
which must be the one she wrote about
the 2022 or whenever it took place
Woodsboro Massacre all of these theater
Shrine items were part of Richie
kirsch's Collection despite the fact
that he claims that the first stab movie
is the only good one he dies in Scream
2022 so it makes sense that there
wouldn't be much from that movie however
I did notice the stab Blu-ray box set
which was released at some point between
screams four and five if there's one
thing you can usually count on in or
equal it's the new characters taking up
the mantle of the Legacy characters in
the case of scream Sam Carpenter is the
new Sydney Prescott and she puts on the
Ghostface costume to fight back against
detective bayley at the end of the movie
It's the very same Ghost Face costume
that Sydney wore to strike back against
Billy Loomis approximately 27 years
earlier and just like Billy bayley finds
himself on the wrong end of a ghost face
call from his prey
hello detective Bailey
hello are you alone in the house Bailey
is not the only one to suffer a very
1996 phase Ethan pops up in the final
reel for one last scare and gets crushed
by the same TV that fell upon Stu mocker
so what's the message this time what are
the filmmakers trying to tell us well
it's not that different from the last
movie this is kind of the second one in
a row that condemns toxic internet
culture this time instead of toxic
fandom it's about the phenomenon of
Reddit detectives who try to solve
crimes on their own and usually just end
up making things worse wavy web surf has
a really good video on the topic if you
want to learn more throughout the movie
Sam has to deal with accusations that
she was actually the killer in Woodsboro
like this guy who refers to her as being
that psycho girl he looks like he could
be an actual redditor another chick
recognizes her dumps Diet Cherry Coke on
her and calls her a murderer why would
you dump a beverage on someone if you
believe she was a murderer that is not a
smart move even her psychiatrist starts
to get creeped out by her if you're like
me you probably wanted to go back and
look at the names in the psychiatrist's
filing cabinet to see if there were any
Easter eggs as far as I can tell these
are just random patient names with no
deeper meaning but Mars Jupiter is
definitely a weird one perhaps the
biggest twist with this movie is that
none of the core characters die it
looked like Chad was a goner there for a
minute but he miraculously makes it out
on a stretcher at the end although
during that part where Tara takes off
his oxygen mask to kiss him I wish he
just would have died right there it
would have been so [__] funny click
the playlist on the left for more of my
scream franchise analysis videos and if
you want to see everything you might
have missed in the upcoming Scream 7
then make sure you subscribe to cz's
world for new Horrors every week ring
the death bell for all notifications and
I will see you in the next one assuming
we both survive
please
foreign